[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are making a video
based on this very interesting
suggestion that's right today we're
going to be ranking the top 10 worst
works in my hero academia if you guys
have a video you really want to see
leave your suggestion in the comments
and it may just be the next video we
make now before I go on I want to make
something clear any quirk can be useful
if you know how and when to use it and
this includes the quirks on this list
not to mention the fact that quirks can
be honed and improved upon through
practice so what is more important that
the quirk in many cases is the user and
how they make use of their quirks as
Crimson Riot says as long as you have a
manly spirit it doesn't matter what kind
of quirk you have however you guys asked
for it so in this video I'll share the
top 10 worst quirks in my opinion
although these quirks can be useful in
specific contexts when it comes to
fighting against opponents with quirks
of their own I feel that these tank
works are quite weak in general it
should also be noted that most of the
quirks we have seen so far belong to pro
heroes or students that have been
accepted at the prestigious heroes
schools so it's not like these quirks
are going to be completely terrible or
useless
they just don't measure up to the other
quirks in my view feel free to let me
know about your own personal picks for
worst and weakest quirk in the comments
section below by the way we just created
a poll on Twitter about what type of
videos anime uproar should make in the
future feel free to follow us on twitter
at anime uproar and vote for your
favorite option if you enjoy my new
wrekidy mia videos and want to see more
of them make sure the troit smash that
like button then let me know and if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
well I'll do my best to avoid major
spoilers in this video in case you
haven't caught up to the manga now
without further ado let's do this
number 10 first up we have Jose
subanallah from class 1b and his quirk
is Solidaire the quirk type is emitter
and it works at close range
solid air is pretty self-explanatory it
let's call say solidify air and create a
barrier in the process you
his bread he can create a solid wall and
his potential size is limited by closes
own lung capacity it's interesting to
note that the air walls will not fall to
the ground but rather they will stay
afloat even if other characters are
hanging off of them so this quirk sounds
like it could be pretty useful it can
create a barrier to deflect attacks or
prevent people from following call safe
especially if they are indoors within a
relatively confined space so that the
opponent cannot simply go around the
wall there's no effective offensive
capabilities that we've seen for this
quirk but at least it can theoretically
make for a good defense right well not
really
Baku goal can break the barrier with a
punch that doesn't even cause any
noticeable damage to his hand so at its
most useful the pork may be able to slow
the enemy down a bit perhaps colse can
make the air wall stronger with practice
but as of now I definitely think this is
one of the weakest quirks that we've
seen in mine hero academia number nine
mustard is a member of the league of
villains Vanguard action squad and his
quirk is called sleep-gas
his quirk lets him generate and control
this gas and obviously anyone who
inhales too much of it will fall asleep
so although it will not directly hurt
the opponent it seems like a pretty
useful port kind of like Jigglypuff's
lullaby however there are significant
drawbacks
imagine if Jigglypuff made herself fall
asleep every time she's saying that's
more or less the situation with mustard
he's not immune from his own sleep
inducing gas which means he always has
to wear a gas mask and that makes it
much more difficult to catch enemies
off-guard because everyone would be
suspicious if they just saw a dude with
a gas mask walk in there are also many
ways around the power if the opponent
has a gas mask can make a gas mask like
Momo or is fast enough to steal mustards
gas mask then the quirk is rendered
useless furthermore it is easy to
disperse the gas if you have a quirk or
weapon that can produce gusts of wind
like big fists finally the fact that
mustard has to carry around the revolver
shows how weak and insufficient his
quirk is he still needs a conventional
weapon to make up for the failings of
his quirk number eight Yuga a Yama
is a member of class 1a and his quirk is
called Mabel laser navel laser lets you
go
shoot short or long range beams from his
belly button and he can even use the
recoil of the beam to propel himself
through the air at high speeds this
could have been a good work if it were
not for its major limitation if you got
uses it for more than a second or two
he'll get a stomachache rendering him
unfit for battle apparently if he uses
it too much
his tummy can even collapse furthermore
he is always wearing his sparkle belt
when he uses the power suggesting that
if he were to lose or break the belt he
wouldn't be able to use his power at all
although useful at times all of its
conditions and side effects make UGA's
quirk one of the worst in my view number
seven also a member of class 1a Minoru
Mineta in his quirk Popoff come in at
seventh place Mina toss quirk lets him
produce sticky balls on his head that he
can pull off and throw at opponents if
he's lucky
Vanetta square can trap the enemy in
place he can stick people to the wall to
the floor to objects or to other people
the stickiness does not affect Moneta
and the balls will grow back but if he
uses the power too much he will start to
bleed all mean it's a signature move
great brush involves as him running
towards his opponent throwing his balls
at them and hoping that they get stuck
so he can escape by running past them in
certain situations Mina the square can
compliment other quirks nicely but on
its own it is quite weak it does not
make for a good attack or defense
especially if the opponent is fast and
agile it will be interesting to see how
Miatas usage of his quirk evolves but
for now it seems like using his quirk in
combination with other quirks like he
did when facing off against villains at
the usj rather than trying to take on
opponents by himself is his best bet
number 6
Yasu Alison is a class 1 B student and
his quirk is called weld this quirk is
similar to minute us but it works at
close range while minute us can work
from a variety of distances weld allows
Yosa to to melt or fuse things together
if he is touching both objects so the
end result is more or less the same as
pop off but it is much more difficult to
use Josette's who needs to be touching
both objects or people he wants to meld
together so the technique would be
useless against all but the slow
opponents he would probably be the star
employee in an automobile factory but on
the battlefield his quirk is pretty
useless and even less versatile than me
notice number 5 May hot woman is from
class one age
she's from UAE's department of support
where she helps fix improve and create
cool hero equipment her quirk is called
zoom and just like it sounds it lets her
zoom into faraway objects or people her
quirk is kind of like having glorified
binoculars built into your eyes it is
impressive that she can see things from
up to 5 kilometers away but it's a
pretty useless quirk when it comes to
combat especially since your opponent
will in all likelihood be relatively
close to you
rendering the zoom power unnecessary
however Mays real power comes from her
mind her intelligence is an impressive 5
out of 5 according to the my hero
academia data book she uses her brains
to create powerful and useful weapons
her quirk probably comes in handy while
she is creating her inventions but not
so much on the battlefield in the end
there's a reason that she needed to use
her inventions to compete against the
other students during the tournament art
rather than the hero program she
definitely belongs at the department of
support and it's pretty clear that she
prefers it this way after all she only
competed in the tournament so that she
could show off her inventions to
potential investors
hatsune way will always be more of a
genius and mentor than a fighter number
4 next up we have Misaki mizushima aka
the pro hero manual aka lumen Rider
no but seriously as soon as we were
introduced to manual I couldn't help but
think of lumen Rider from one punch man
they're just super ordinary dudes who
just want to help others even the kanji
and Misaki can be read to mean regular
or ordinary in fact manuals so ordinary
or average that he got 3 out of 5 in
every category in the my hero academia
data book his quirk is generically
called water-clerk it simply lets him
gather some water around his hands
perhaps this would help him fight
against fire Pokemon but I can't see it
being very useful in the my hero
academia world it's safe to assume as
with Moomin Ryder manual primarily
relies on his physical strength when
fighting opponents rather than rely on
and
kind of quark or superpower although
personally that only makes me respect
these two heroes even more taking on
dangerous criminals or villains without
any good superpowers is a sign of true
courage number three
next we have decals bomb in call me
Dottie
I thought her clerk would be related to
the waterfalls that regularly spring
from her eyes but no her actual quirk
has been referred to as attraction of
small objects she can surprise surprise
attract small objects to her body now
this power would be awesome for everyday
use you can attract the remote to you if
it's out of reach without getting off
the couch or you could get your car keys
if they fall on the ground without
bending over to pick them up so it's
definitely convenient power to have when
you're feeling kind of lazy but in terms
of combat it's definitely one of the
weakest quirks it would be cool if inco
could control small objects like a small
but deadly blade but she can't really
control anything she can't send anything
in an opponent's direction only bring it
slowly to herself in the end although it
could be a fun and useful quirk for US
civilian to have it would not serve a
hero well in combat number two next we
have the dazzling unnamed baby that was
born in China it was the first quark
that was ever discovered and it caused
the baby to glow we know that the baby
could light up a room with its glow but
also that the father of the baby could
look at it without being blinded by the
light thus the quark pretty much turns
the possessor into a human light bulb
the human emanates light and best-case
scenario the quark could with enough
practice allow the user to do a solar
flare type move and fly the opponent for
some moments but this court can easily
be overcome with a cool pair of shades
the fact that the possessor glows makes
it even harder for them to conduct sneak
attacks and catch the enemy by surprise
so since the best that this court could
probably do is make an opponent squint
that night it makes sense that it would
be so high up on this list on the bright
side with this quirk you could read
books or manga all night long without
having to pay expensive electricity
bills
so come to think of it I wouldn't mind
having this power myself number one
and finally the number one
weakest and worst quirk in the my hero
academia universe is one for all well
sorta
to be specific it's one of the two
quirks that came together to create the
one for all quirk that our protagonist
inherited from all night if you don't
know I'll tell you the origin of one for
all without giving too many spoiler
asked details once upon a time there
were two brothers the older brother who
could take works and use them for
himself or transfer them on to others
gave his seemingly quickness brother a
quirk that allowed him to stockpile
power however this little brother wasn't
actually quark list he had a quirk that
allowed him to pass on his squirt to
another these two quirks merged and
created one for all
it is the quirk that allows one to pass
on a quark that I think is probably the
worst quark in my ear academia if it
weren't for the very unlikely event of
having a quark transferred to him by
someone else
the younger brother would have simply
died without knowing he ever had a quark
also if his brother didn't happen to
have that extremely convenient power he
would not have exhibited any special
power at all throughout his whole life
he could have been quick less and there
literally would have been no difference
however as I said before under the right
circumstances if the stars align even
the worst quirks can be extremely useful
the older brother happened to give the
younger brother the stockpile and quark
and it combined with what was previously
an utterly pointless quark and created
one of the strongest quirks in the my
hero academia world and I think that's
one of the coolest things about my hero
academia even the weakest person in
quark has the potential to become the
strongest and there it is guys the top
10 worst quirks in my opinion I bet you
never guessed that in a way the weakest
and worst quark was in Deku albeit in a
mutated and greatly enhanced form but
still it's pretty interesting if you
think about it thank you so much for
watching guys we really appreciate the
support you guys have given us I mean
we're almost at fifty thousand subs
that's crazy if you enjoyed this video I
want to see more like it make sure that
Detroit smash that like button and leave
any suggestions for future videos you
want to see and
comments below if you haven't already be
sure to subscribe for more
my hero academia greatness and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]